I've never made pancake mix in this
quantity this is very very have you
gonna say like 15 pounds of batter
open your eyes guys oh I'm a little
turned on right now I thank
sup guys to Melvin I love making giant
food and today on taste he's making a
big we're gonna do some crazy stuff Ned
and Zack from the try guys are coming in
I'm super excited because I've always
been a huge fan of their videos they do
these crazy things and they never back
down from a challenge I don't think I
will either I'll be challenging myself
to make the giant food of their dreams
so let's go see what they want me to
make for them so guys for a while you
guys enough in the last year we launched
a new youtube channel youtube.com slash
and try guys and now we are going on a
nationwide tour we have a new book
coming out june 8 t it's all the hidden
power of yeah what's this book about
self-help book from for people that
can't help themselves
you guys are like no strangers to like
food videos yeah we love making food
videos and that has a food series
actually fun fact Ned and I are the
brunch boys of the tribes fun now get
some ins memos so guys you guys waffle
guys what do you see what's your perfect
oh I think we all know that the greatest
mood we know we're both obviously the
same thing one two three wha what it
sounds like you guys have different
opinions on what your favorite food
might be I'm gonna make something giant
for you guys what should I make
look I don't think you're gonna get a
waffle iron big enough that is true
here's the gauntlet I'm throwing David
if you make me a giant fluffy pancake
okay it's delicious
perhaps you can convince me okay all
right guys I'm gonna get to work I'll
see you guys in a bit you guys feel free
to hang out but I'm gonna see if I can
make your dream come true I'm gonna see
I can create one of your first memories
of pancakes to be the best thing ever
[Music]
let's make these pancakes you're gonna
be pretty big so we have a lot of batter
to get through
dumping a lot of eggs and we're also
gonna dump it in a lot of milk oh you're
like the rappers in the music video they
like for champagne this is actually a
family recipe it's been passed down for
many generations this one is by my aunt
we call her aunt J you know her very
very famous secret pancake recipe my
Uncle Ben kind of fights over it he'd
rather you know eat rice instead of
pancakes so that's kind of how it goes
who was looking nice so I don't know if
you guys have seen I made a 100 layer of
lasagna video and that one kind of use
foil as the walls I kind of want to take
that idea and make a pancake ring to
kind of cook in this pan over here do
some origami over here so this ring goes
into this pan let that hang out give it
a nice spray - the worst part about
making pancakes every time you pour the
batter into the pan it always kind of
gets everywhere I don't think there's a
solution for that okay so if this
pancake has been cooking for about five
to ten minutes it kind of looks done on
the side so let's give it a check okay
so batter on top was a little raw that's
fine if you flip it hopefully it's okay
well I don't know if you guys can see
that's burnt I don't think this
technique is working out so well so I
think the issue is I need a pan that's
thicker and bigger hand we're gonna go
and try to find a bigger pan
okay I couldn't square anymore oh wait
this is perfect this is our pea pan I
think this is gonna work perfectly so
let's go for round two okay let's put
this big boy to work I actually set up a
double hot plate situation because this
guy's gonna need a lot of heat I'm
naming him Jim you will be my guide for
today and we're going to see if you can
make the big package that I want to make
this kind of feels like I'm making a
pancake for an entire village
here we go that was an entire box of
pancake mix I'm a family recipe I'm
gonna check it when the edges are
starting to firm up and a lot of bubbles
are coming through and fingers crossed
because this pan was a godsend and want
to make a big pancake see you guys in a
bit so it's been like 20 minutes as you
can see it's kind of looking a little
weird there's like a ring of like
semi-cooked batter on the outside I'm
gonna say it's pretty much raw I think
the issue is that there is actually not
enough heat to cook this pancake through
I don't want all this batter to go to
waste so I'm gonna send this to the
kitchen and they're just gonna make some
really nice pancake bread pudding I'll
be right back for a hopefully the
correct attempt to making this giant
pancake because this is heavy Jim is not
cooperating right now I have a plan for
a different kind of batter that I think
we'll be able to do correctly so we're
just gonna melt a lot of butter because
everything tastes better with it
essentially what this is it is a more of
a japanese-style pancake and essentially
they made a lighter batter that was more
focused on egg whites to help make it
fluffy and instead of cooking it
directly on the pan and flipping it they
kind of cooked it almost like an esteem
or in a grill kind of oven situation so
that they rose a lot and they kept their
shape and the heat was even so I'm gonna
kind of go for that
so this butter is just going to melt
that's looking pretty melted I'm just
gonna take that off on the next thing
that we're gonna do that was part of a
lot of the japanese-style pancakes was
the egg whites so got a nice trusty old
stand mixer here I'll name you Dave
we've got Dave and we got Jim hanging
out in the back
rusty buddies for the giant pancake so
it's gonna get egg whites in here so
we're gonna whip these egg whites until
they get soft in Peaks and then we're
gonna fold them into the rest of the
batter so this we're gonna do the melted
butter and then we're gonna add some
warm milk and then we're gonna add in
more beautiful egg yolks nice and foamy
pull in this big bowl I'm gonna do flour
and we're gonna do some baking powder
where they get this in here oh look at
Dave over there he's doing work these
egg whites looking nice and fluffy
thanks Dave we're going to gently flip
these in to the batter I need to do the
double folding technique I'm pretty sure
this is not how we're supposed to do it
sorry
pastry chefs sometimes you gotta just
roll with the punches pretty optimistic
about this batter so this is nice it is
silky it looks pretty smooth so we're
just gonna transfer this to give a Jim
hopefully one more last attempt that's
nice
okay so I do want to smooth this out a
little bit this is very nice very smooth
I'm going to actually take this to our
grill and pray that it does work so
fingers crossed and I'll see you guys
out there whoa you're a heavy boy Jim is
your name Dave I forgot so this is our
grill I'm glad that the pan fits
perfectly within the grill we're gonna
turn it on to about 300 or so degrees so
we're gonna go let this guy hang out
hopefully it's fully cooked and really
nice and golden-brown by the end of it
pretty nervous so we'll see please it's
been 45 minutes I hopefully think that's
enough time to cook this pancake I
really want to see what it looks like so
here we go
whoa this is crazy
holy crap it's like a giant souffle
biscuit which is pretty cool okay
there's a couple of cracks I think
that's fine we're gonna turn it out the
cracks are gonna be on the bottom
anyways
all right let's go back and flip this
out okay so we have one successful
pancake attempt the battle is not over
yet we do have to flip this guy but I
think I'm gonna put this tray on top and
they kind of do something like this this
is really really heavy okay what this
guy looks like this is a pancake that is
right it is a cake made in this pan it's
like so smooth it's like a baby's this
is one successful pancake for the try
guys I don't think they would be
satisfied with just one pancake I'm
gonna need to make at least four to five
more but before I do that I do want to
tackle the butter so this is four entire
sticks of butter that have been softened
so if you think about it each stick of
butter has eight tablespoons so if we
use all of this we're gonna have a
butter score that's 32 times the size of
a normal butter square that's a lot of
butter I feel like I should name this
guy to call this guy Jimbo cuz we got
Jim and then we have Jimbo I'm gonna
stop talking now and put this butter
square in the freezer so see you guys
soon
[Music]
Oh - oh boy here we go one two three
okay this is the second one okay
that's two I will name you this guys
Kevin this is the third one okay better
at this okay okay you can be George - Oh
easy for hope you kind of fell off the
plate a little bit that's okay I know
what to name me right now it's okay I'll
name you later
sometimes you don't name your kids till
later hope my arms don't fail me oh
that's a nice-looking one I'll then this
guy keep peeing here today but I'll name
a pancake after him this is the final
pancake that might be the best one yet I
want to name this guy Eugene just like
Eugene pretty nice flawless skin so we
have one two three four five six giant
pancakes it has been a journey and the
only thing left is to assemble them so
we have all hands on deck at all our
pancakes we got some berries you got
some syrup I'm going to try and be
careful with my children as much as I
can all right Jim first up where are all
you guys look alike oh my god Jim is
very resilient Jim can take a beating
that's why he goes on first because he's
gonna be under all the other children
he's gonna be taking all the pressure
putting the whole team on his back
literally so thanks Jim all right Kevin
and Jim on deck George has his two
brothers supporting him so he'll be able
to rise and shine just like the rest of
us
and then fourth we got the problem child
the guy that I forgot to give a name oh
okay that's for keeps on keeps on last
but not least a boy Eugene I think he
deserves it he's not here today I think
he deserves a little bit of a spotlight
oh okay that is huh that's a pretty big
stack of pancakes icon here this is my
piece there is a stones here we are
finishing touches I hoping that ends
Accra happy within if they eat it
they'll be eating Keith in Eugene first
oh this is for Tiger sticks butter we
got oh there it is I don't really know
how heavy it is I just want to see I
can't even but that is definitely at
least 50 pounds and just so you guys can
see this is a normal sized stack of
pancakes I would say this is success I
didn't think I could be able to do this
but I'm glad it worked out I think it
looks awesome and I hope the try guys
like it oh so I have your pancakes ready
but first I just wanted you guys to see
the size of the serum so that was same
area so that tells you anything about
how this is gonna go I'll be right back
close your eyes okay okay okay oh thank
you well the pancakes are on the table
on the count of three I want you guys to
open your eyes and see what I made for
you one two three open your eyes guys
how do you feel that a waffle is ever
gonna stand up whoa wha who could never
stand that tall how did you do this so
for this pancake ax had to get a paia
pan so I made a bunch of batter and we
made six of these big ones for you guys
can I touch it
yes you can touch it this is all yours
yes it's got nice nice outer yes this is
what your baby feels like everyone you
every time you do it true what one
second I do have one more surprise for
you guys hold on here now it's a brunch
so I know you guys talked about mins
cheers Cheers
you guys want to start eating your
pancakes I will let you guys do the
syrup pouring the part
[Music]
oh my god we have giant pancakes but we
have regular-sized forks and knives for
you
joy pancakes is you got to get more than
one layer in a fight okay good you have
a nice crispness to the top there's a
top layer but then very fluffy on the
inside yeah so Zach how do you feel now
now you've had this stack if you change
your mind about pancakes at all you can
make me pancakes whenever you want
that's what I like to hear whoo I'm
actually personally curious to see a
cross section you have to feed it to us
oh here you go careful of the knife the
knife is on the bottom the middle toes
even better my hands are sticky but
thank you we love to brunch but I think
the joy of brunch is also the joy of
sharing and I like love if we could
share this with people here that sounds
like a good idea I'm gonna go call some
friends
I think love pancakes and we're gonna
bring them in to help you demolish this
brunch team assemble
[Music]
whoa it's been a crazy fun adventure
made a lot of pancakes but I'm really
happy that Ned and Zach enjoyed why I
made for them you want to take a guess
at what I'm gonna be making next feel
free to drop it in the comments send me
a message I'll be doing a lot of crazy
things and I can't wait to show you guys
what I have in store so until then peace
[Music]